previously on TV sins what in the name
of Charles Schulz is that growing on
this street is this the great pumpkin
growing on this apple tree did I just
crack a code or is this just a 1966
animation flub of the Sun rising too
close to a drawing of a tree leaning the
ladder and the animator said let's have
Linus pick up an apple and only take one
bite of it before throwing it away even
though it's actually his sister who is
truly the [ __ ] why does this
neighborhood have no sidewalks no
garages and no streets I mean you can
shout all you want about them not
wanting to complicate the animation but
they animated a freaking electric pole
so I'm not buying it hold on there
animators are you telling me that this
Sun is the same Sun as here and here
I mean I know perspective can change but
we've been following these two the whole
way so the Sun should have followed
along with them what's up that's my
three sons situation is this a Star Wars
oh ma honestly if the Peanuts gang live
on Tatooine that explains so much
welcome to our coldest axe pumpkin patch
every call to sack has a pumpkin patch
right
Gor Jamie great move by lioness here but
exactly what purpose does a fence like
this serve also did he leave his blanket
in the pumpkin patch
apparently all it took to cure him of
his blanket fetish was jacking his
lantern a bit linus survives this I'm 63
percent sure that Vince Guaraldi's
incredible music is 91 percent
responsible for 76 percent of these
peanuts specials get and I'm pretty sure
all that math adds up to me having to
remove at least recent I'm not certain
all the evidence lines up perfectly but
I'd wager all the money is that Lucy
grew up to be the Zodiac killer geez
Lucy why even put the paper towels out
in the first place my sentiment all but
Linus has seen jack-o'-lanterns before
right I mean the one thing I know for
sure after watching this is that Linus
has a seriously disturbing obsession
with pumpkins why do these multitude of
holes change into a normal three-hole
Ghostface when this trick-or-treater
gets scared by the way multitude of
holes was also the title of my college
girlfriends tell-all autobiography -
seeing the string on the cat still count
as a sin in an animated show I'm gonna
go with yes also the show is a dick to
people suffering from triple phobia if
time you can trust me see here's a
signed document how nearsighted is
Charlie Brown how can he see anything
with the paper that close to his face
dear great pumpkin writing I mean
reading I mean both why are you going to
stop believing in something that isn't
true like Lucy holding the football for
a truck pop and kettle CB pot and kettle
the beat number two perhaps here try
harder the DCU
also in case you needed any proof that
pop-culture references don't age well
this line was originally a wink to a
popular slogan for Avis rent-a-car oh
the hilarity pretty sure those 2-cent
counseling booths you set up don't help
matters Lucille I wonder why I'll pound
you isn't a sibling threat used off in
these days Oh
they're never to discuss with people
religion politics and the Great Pumpkin
strangely in 2019 these are somehow all
the same topic well the hell was that
Lucy just go recruit random friends to
the Raider brother on random street
urchins wandering off the street to add
their ridicule to for Linus everyone
tells me you are a fake but I believe in
you PS if you really are a fake don't
tell me I don't want to know Republicans
ok fine enough political humor but
honestly tell me this doesn't become
about a thousand times more interesting
when you think of it as a modern
political commentary all those red
scribbling supposed to indicate Linus is
embarrassed because it seems more likely
to indicate atopic dermatitis well that
or you let your three-year-old do the
animation coloring for this part I have
to give credit to the animators for
their profound ability to predict how
the US Postal Service would become
obsolete by removing the letter from
Linus's hand for a single frame
brilliant this works also there is an
abbreviation dot after you but not after
s peanuts MP Shelley how do we do it I
don't know how old Sally's supposed to
be but I'm guessing she's at least knows
what the trick-or-treating is years old
taking part in a rumble there was
clearly only two holes in that sheet
when he was holding it a second ago
also this explains nothing would be one
thing if you had cut this thing to
shreds but those cups are all fairly
consistent ovals wouldn't you just stop
after - like so many problems this one
could have been avoided if you weren't
so obsessed with your holes there are
many things about Charlie Brown that
hold up really well representing poverty
by showing Pigpen being dirty with bugs
flying around him all the time it's not
one of them
makes you wonder if this is what caused
the dogs being dressed up in Halloween
costumes Chris and if so that is a
hundred percent of sin and the holes are
gone again don't talk like that the
Great Pumpkin knows which kids have been
good and which kids have been bad -
thinking the Great Pumpkin exists is one
thing but thinking he's like Santa and
brings gifts is another the fact that he
hasn't actually got many gifts on
previous Halloween's didn't cool him in
you come here because I have the most
sincere pumpkin patch and he respects
sincerity watching these peanuts
specials today is the equivalent of
watching a show that Steven Levitan
created that wrote every single
character to be Manny from Modern Family
you don't believe the story of the Great
Pumpkin I thought little girls always
believed everything that was told to
them that's racist well that's Aly sure
does run hot and cold there doesn't she
I don't care what you say there was a
giant face in the sky that is about to
eat those children and I will never be
able to unsee it an animated character
with five fingers what is this sorcery
and now she's back to four all is right
with the world again I got five pieces
of candy I got chocolate bars I got a
quarter I got a rock Charlie Brown will
now get a rock from all the houses on
his block and I have to ask what kind of
sick ass community is this the adults
obviously had to have a town meeting and
not only decided to single out Charlie
Brown but actually concoct and enact a
plan that involved a identifying which
costume was his and B setting aside time
to collect rocks to have ready to throw
in his bag this plan is as diabolical as
it is unreasonable also the I got a rock
bit is a great recurring joke but I'm
more confused about the other two
exclamations everyone other than Charlie
Brown clearly got more than five pieces
of candy and we didn't see a quarter
thrown into any of the bags also awesome
who the [ __ ] is this I got a quarter kit
got pig pen Lucy Charlie Brown another
witch and the Davy Crockett ghost but
this kid is nowhere to be seen did they
pick up an actual ghost at some point
that would've been a much more
interesting side story than the Red
Baron both speaking of the Red Baron
book the section goes on for a little
over two and a half minutes and barely
anyone remembers it you know why because
it sucks this is the most ridiculous
amount of padding since my sister
decided to 12 that she wanted her
shoulders to be as high as the top of
her head this reminds me why is CB so
follically challenged Charles Schulz
said he never considered him to be bald
just really light hair it seems like
this
pletely contradict that idea I just need
some headcanon on the issue so I can
move on in order to imagine Charlie's
mom shaves his head every morning in
this exact formation as a way to remind
her of a milkman with male pattern
baldness that she had an affair with in
the 50s he died tragically when his
curiosity got the best of him I don't
know if bottle broke in a very sensitive
area since she could never admit her
forbidden love this hairstyle is her
only way to hold his memory in her heart
yeah it'll work awesome what other way
were they going to set up the
jack-o'-lantern that's like literally
every jack-o'-lanterns facial features
and there was no paper to draw on just
saying much like the sin this is a super
long way to get to a joke that's not
funny to begin with this sign says Snoop
Dogg is just three kilometers from the
mall solan flats when just a few moments
ago he walked by a sign saying he was 70
kilometers from so allah subhana since
those cities are 138 kilometers apart
the closest he could have been to this
city was 65 kilometers which is easily a
14-hour walk next we see he's a few
kilometers from Allah mouths and which
is another 35 kilometers seven-hour walk
and my point is I suck at pronouncing
French city names also this line takes
him deeper into German occupied
territory so I'm not sure exactly where
he's headed who Bob's for apples on
carpet last time we saw snoops he was
ducking behind a curtain and we never
cut away from the apple bucket so I
think it's safe to assume that beagles
have mastered teleportation sorry Lucy a
dog's mouth is cleaner than a mate who
says what no fine apparently the facts
behind this I'm much more complicated
than a simple answer it involves
different types of bacteria and let's
have a food a dog eats in the word
zoonotic so sing away Lucy but no though
you aren't all wrong you aren't all
right either Shorter's hands are too big
or that piano is too small for him to be
able to play it well with both hands
either way I'm calling Schroeder
shenanigans also this goes on for some
time
seriously stretch must have been written
in the screenplay on every other page
also also Schroeder's playing the world
war 1 hit it's a long way to tipperary a
song about missing home that soldiers on
both sides made their own however
eventually the bored soldiers changed
the lyrics to that's the wrong way to
tickle Mary and I like to think that
Snoopy's goofy grin here is because he's
imagining that version in his head
instead you know Snoopy had his way with
those French [ __ ] what he's a dog
isn't he
aha we caught the animators blue head I
mean we've got Sally red-handed I mean
cut the animators redheaded making Sally
blue Hannah
whatever her hands blue dang it let's
move on it should be mentioned that
Linus did not force or even really
persuade Sally into staying
with him he just asked if she wanted to
and if he had known there would be this
much of Sally shouting he might not have
asked in the first place the only thing
more exaggerated than this Sally rant is
that holy sized moon behind her that's
probably the Bruce Almighty is moon to
ever almighty capo culture nice a loosey
to go get her brother but where though
got the parents I see you show try to
make me feel like Lucy is doing a good
thing she's done nothing but treat her
brother like a Linus infection this
entire time if you think tucking him in
one time makes it all better you're
talking nuts Twitter over here pile of
rocks waving at you yeah okay that is
the last time you are gonna pull that
crap the beat number two perhaps you try
harder
I'm gonna pee on your head and visit
your Dead skull
[Music]